le coc vide a bouleversé le quotidien et
les pratiques des professionnels du
funéraire à magny les hameaux les pompes
funèbres indique ont repris un rythme
relativement normal mais il garde un
traumatisme de la première vague on ne
faisait plus de transport de corps avant
mise en bière
donc dans une eau sanitaire à visage
découvert mais on faisait ont pratiqué
n'est mise en bière sur place sur le
lieu du décès sans présence famille
c'était aussi assez traumatisant pour le
personnel un des pompes funèbres
parce que c'est pas facile de devenir
comme ça et puis de faire une mise en
bière immédiatement de fermer un
cercueil
voilà on on sent bien qui va manquer
quelque chose à la famille jour et nuit
entre mars et mai 2020 il était appelé
les décès s'enchaîner à l'hôpital on
vient d'arriver il ya déjà un corbillard
qui est parti avant nous et puis quand
on revient et à mettre le cercueil dans
note dans notre corbillard il ya déjà un
corbillard qui arrive pour vous allez
donc tout ça c'est assez traumatisant
effectivement il a aussi fallu
accompagner les familles des défunts
plus que d'habitude on a essayé de faire
le trait d'union c'est à dire le lien
entre le défunt et la famille parce que
cette famille qui n'avait pas vu leurs
proches avant la mort au monde la mort
et après la mort au moment où se ferment
le cercueil
eh bien on on essayait peut-être deux
comment de les rassurer de leur
expliquer comment on avait pu prendre le
corps mais aussi faire savoir aux
familles que leurs défunts ont été
respectées on a toujours tenu aussi à
préparer nos cercueil qu'ovide ou non
qu'ovide exactement de la même manière
c'est à dire que les capitons il est
repassé on prenait soin des personnes
aujourd'hui le calme est revenu aux
pompes funèbres indique les mises en
bière même pour des cas qu'ovide peuvent
se faire trois jours après le décès mais
à ce jour les professionnels n'ont
toujours pas d'information sur la
contagiosité du virus post mortem